hello guys I'm Ryan right
I'm Jerry I'm Tony yeah very cool very
cool and calm I like it Tony Gill is
literally my next-door neighbor
we ended up bonding he's a great human
being we partake in some medication
together yes yes and it's a don't go to
dialysis we both go to dialysis
we have kidney property where did I
check out a trailer for sausage party
it's the red band trailer starring
Kristen Wiig James Franco I thinks it's
a Seth Rogen film as well yeah there are
ton of people in this movie and the
wikipedia page has been up for a while
and like the casting is pretty funny
there are a lot of voices cool cool I'm
looking forward to I haven't heard of
this movie really I've never heard of it
first time and sausage party perfect for
today yeah heritable sausage let's get
the game thing out of the way guys come
on let's do this oh come on boy have sex
we all need to experience just one time
oh I mean I'm not gay but we can try I
already ejaculated not into it key
moment of truth that me a jacket with a
meteor not into it like not maybe you're
so into it I just feel Catholic guilt
when I come oh yeah everybody they
rewrote that way don't know it I like
red band trailers Sony and if you
ketchup mustard Oh sausage isn't bonus
here
get up straight boys Hey look at this
with that one yes we're chosen hey
Brenda you and me I'm so happy that
God's put our packages together like we
were made for each other feels amazing
oh yes like the first to enter eternity
bleep step
so it is a Montgomery cetera okay it's
also you of learning the terrible truth
I gotta tell everyone no one will
believe you
I have to try everyone will die
otherwise oh yeah that's a good point
once you see that [__]
little [__] you up for good luck have
fun holy [__] yeah that wasn't a light
that is sausage part I don't know if the
light is the problem that was hilarious
I haven't cracked up that much at a
trailer and so long from that synopsis I
read on Wikipedia this is a little
different than I was led to believe like
I thought this would be more of a comedy
and this looks kind of terrifying well I
think that's what Seth Rogen and Evan
Goldberg do well yeah is John rakamma DS
yeah Alex this is the end was like a
horror comedy and I Charlie providing a
horror element to this family theme what
I wonder if that's if this is gonna be a
similar experience because I left this
is the end more like kind of weirded out
and likely I left with all the horror
stuff I wasn't like I was so funny I was
like that was kind of upsetting like in
an enjoyable way and I wonder if this
will kind of straddle that line to where
it's funny but it's also kind of you
know have yourself yeah one I guess with
the the Seth Rogen films it you always
see I mean it's always crazy and like
gets really rugged in the middle and at
the end they always have like that
delight like even a pineapple Express
with oli meant diner I feel like they're
gonna get a nice little ending but I
mean we just get to see what food get D
yeah and they least Royd they like dark
violent humor I really got the strong
comedy vibe the second I was like I just
look at her right now actually up the
fancy dogs in the glamour buns yeah I
need to grow up
no it's absurd it's funny like this is
basically like the OP like the negev
zone world of a Pixar movie cuz it's
like Oh what if food head feel oh god
don't be [__] up of food eggs because
like we destroy them all day that's the
conflicting part that I feel like am I
gonna walk away from this not wanting to
eat food no no lies isn't how it works
like I watched utopia and I'm like
I should be kinder to all animals Oh
Malik abusive animals or anything well
no the point is you should be kinder to
everyone from Zoo Toby like it's about
people I know but it's like it's one of
those things when I'm watching this I'm
like this is gonna make me feel bad
about you like when I saw Toy Story I
literally thought my toys had emotions
and sometimes I still do
never brand your toys after I burned all
my toys and I heard them all scream I'm
a weed okay see I was always more
sentimental about those things put mine
in the street
better get run over glamour but this is
really funny I mean it's just starts off
so fun and enjoyable at the beginning
and uh I know what's gonna happen in it
like as it gets further along it keeps
building the like oh this is so great
that it's this is too great sounds good
at shape and like yeah right when she
takes a potato I don't like oh yeah oh
dear that's so funny I love the concept
of this having food with like be the
emotional characters in the movie and I
gotta say like even though is cuz it's
red band trailer you hear about the cast
you know it's gonna be an r-rated comedy
right when you start watching the
trailer however I was like this feels
like a real family
animated film at first yes and that
hasn't progressed I was like I was like
damn this is the genre splicing that
they do so well they're bringing horror
element to a family like dreamworks got
a movie well and and to varying degrees
I mean Seth Rogen and Evan Goldberg do
seem to know how to make kind of genuine
comedies like for as vulgar or as out
there or as genre crazy as they can get
like there's always a heart somewhere in
there that feels real you know yeah I
believe that they would be able to bring
that to this with their own unique brand
you know Tony I know you're never on
camera and I know it's probably
intimidating being on the side
well Jerry and I talk because we're so
good at talking to each other I mean I
just feel like I'm kind of like a ghost
ray I don't know your sword I mean like
band ghost I kind of like
just get up you guys won't even notice I
was gone I would oh yeah I can't even
notice you were talking right now what
do you think Tony it looks fine man
looks like a first year [__] you know
very nervous Gillian a few looking for
air right now this is cool this is what
happens when you bring a regular human
being in front of the camera um now man
it feels fun because you're gonna get
interested in the characters and all of
a sudden you can see a bunch of them
dying in front of your face it's gonna
seem normal but when you watch like the
carrots get destroyed that that shows
hilarious you just don't even think
about it when you into carrot like what
if they had I wasn't just just now just
rambling I don't know [__] talk you
cut this Becca I'm not cutting any of
this yeah this is like brilliant
material in my eyes all right when
someone feels embarrassed about how they
come across ah yeah it's a great first
video for you
cool thank you this is the process Tony
doesn't like being in front of the
camera I'm making him go against his
fears always behind making him bigger
fear that I will do something he's not
gonna look like I am ocean aliy abused
Tony outside you shouldn't fear I'm
gonna be late into doing what I want I
will destroy you I don't want to show my
back cuz all the lashes that you've
given me oh yeah man Ryan loves to flog
you yeah I know and you know longer yeah
is that like penetration no no it's like
when you wish somebody with a flog it's
a specific kind of like a whip
everything about penetration you know
then you settle you down you know more
commonly used for torture and while we
can create a little more common with
like a bee no I don't want to get
pinched your toy when I hear it's a
pleasure we'll see whatever I want over
here because they're off you've been
kind of shy
I haven't actually what Integra I
penetrated it so not what I thought was
a girl once but wasn't
if you Oh Ryan that's I'm never a joke a
guy like it's tan I didn't sell her his
hair lately comment all right well you
know [__] a [__] doesn't means
game
no that's Jerry John if you're getting
it is it good yeah is it gay is it what
do you want I don't know you're talking
about Lucy one look guys if you're new
to the channel you can subscribe a day
and become a reject the [__] are you
doing on the side of the whole time oh
nothing I was just sitting here
listening to you good reasons Jerry
dank a Stubbs is a yeah is Jerry's
little shows on this channel
Disney Kaplan too many shows of the real
rejects what the de gastos makes an
appearance when they want to oh yeah I
mean we're you know that's just gonna be
like a like a like a pinewood derby car
that you're always tweaking and like
trying to make run just right and one
day we'll crack it it's just you know
we've been very busy upload schedule is
whenever we get around you know what do
you and Tony is my neighbor so if you
get the chance to come to my apartment
you can meet Tony and this benefits him
in no way doing this video and Tony
likes big like 400-pound woman so if
you're one of those who watches this
channel I what I'm gonna start saying to
get these kids to go with it I'm just
gonna start talking about really
inappropriate stuff no to love them or
Canada where's the vagina